so is it true watching Gordon Ramsay rip
people calms you down when I'm writing
and I need to take a break watching him
yell at someone just makes me feel good
I don't know what that says about me but
then I go back to being positive and
nice and and just generally lovely yeah
you are I ke you are in fact speaking of
generally lovely
we've talked so many times on this show
but the way that you met your wife seems
not just generally lovely but absolutely
lovely will you tell us that story you
guys were like in the same place at the
same time yeah I mean you know when you
think of like romance you think of like
oh we met in Paris at the Eiffel Tower
and that's romantic but it's not as
romantic as you know the Hard Rock
Casino in Las Vegas
at the blackjack table with your fantasy
football league she's with her drunk
Bachelorette friends
Bachmann Turner overdrives blasting from
the ceilings and you just make eyes with
each other and you know we're gonna have
three children together one day it's A
Tale As Old As Time Beauty and the Beast
I mean and it's true you guys met and
then did you fly across country to like
meet up with her yes I'm always
contemplating long-distance
relationships how did you make it work
you got to really like the person yeah
they gotta motivate you to motivate you
to get on like seat 24e on like uh
Southwest Airlines
once a week for like eight months that
you you that you have to really like
them and Airline peanuts uh but yeah I
would go I would finish my show I would
go I'd catch a red eye out we'd spend
like 36 hours together and then I would
fly back uh to La very sad uh I know
it's so romantic no actually it really
is it was it was
um what did she do
um that you know really captured your
heart made it worth it like what was her
end of it I mean just it's always a
two-way street it's always a two-way
street I mean anyone that laughs really
hard at me and thinks I'm attractive
right there that's a big two right there
and and sure thank you thank you uh and
I think if you can watch me eat and keep
up with me food wise I think that's
another big thing so right there you got
three reasons why I'm just like this
person is someone who I'm I'm going to
marry I think laughter is our kind of
our little blanket it's like our respite
from all that evilness and it's horrible
things that are out there and if you
find someone who makes you laugh and
they're laughing at you that's the very
important thing they're laughing at you
uh to me I'm like okay we everything
else will fall into place but that's the
first thing that I always connect with
you
every more I couldn't agree more
and you know who else was a healing
genius to this planet is the great Mel
Brooks oh my God the greatest and you
have made history of the World Part Two
yes yes we have it's out now you can
watch it there it is look at that
you look like we're in a band together
what is so cool is I am like who here is
a Mel Brooks fan I mean yes
like he changed the world Young
Frankenstein Blazing Saddles and history
of the World Part One is just one of my
very favorite of Melba I love it there
he is he's so funny
it's so like it's so silly and
irreverent and and you know Mel I think
in his movies he always kind of takes
shots at the people in charge right he's
like a man of the people you know what I
mean he's like in every man and he told
us from day one he's like don't be
afraid to tell dirty jokes it's gonna be
okay you know what we need some dirty
jokes in this world so we really took
him took that to heart and uh some
pretty disgusting jokes in the show we
have a clip let's take a look
okay all right there's one more thing
that I need to talk to you about it's
about my son Robert Todd your son he has
been begging me to enlist and now that
the war is nearly over I feel like this
is the perfect time to just get him in
there once all the regular Fighters have
yes given their lives and fled and lost
their legs now you want to sneak in your
little Harvard boy for a couple days in
the course yes no you understand
absolutely
here we go I just can't thank you enough
for bringing this into the world and Ike
you are such a brilliant comedian and I
know you wrote this and you brought it
into the world and you brought Mel
Brooks with you the greatest icon ever
thank you for putting this into the
world thank you we need it now I love
you yesterday tomorrow now
Ike and I have a long-standing tradition
that we um eat Chicago food because you
know you're a famous Chicago here we go
so um Chicago hot dogs are New York
City's latest food Trend according to
the website that I bowed down to theater
and so we got some Chicago dogs made
here in the Big Apple so shall we try
get in there
a cheers
how do we work
oh my God
it's just a perfect food so this is from
Bobby's Italian beef
um
they nailed it
okay we're gonna cut to a quick
commercial bacon up next we're gonna
celebrate Ike's new show by highlighting
some incredible events that happened
this day in history for history
oh
[Music]
okay